- That tastes exactly like Cap'n
Crunch with Crunch Berries.
- It does.
It does.
(laughing)
I'm actually kind of surprised.
- Laser accuracy.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, my name's Christian,
I'm a BuzzFeed Producer
out in New York.
And I used to be a Starbucks barista
and I know there's a full secret menu
of frappuccinos that taste a lot
like popular breakfast cereals.
I have three odd frappuccino requests.
Now these aren't
officially Starbucks drinks
but they were developed by baristas
so they could emulate the
exact taste of these cereals.
So I figured I would have
some of my co-workers
try some of them.
(upbeat music)
- I love how you would like
the colors a little discerning.
- The color is a little discerning.
- At least with the unicorn
thing was exciting looking
and this is so modest.
- Right, right right.
It's like a off pink.
- It looks kind of like
the color of the milk
after you eat the cereal.
So in that way, I accept
it and I believe in it.
- Should we try it?
- Yeah.
- Alright I'll let you go first.
- Okay, let's see here.
(slurping)
- Oh my God.
- That's actually so good.
- I love it.
- I guess if someone asked me to describe
what Captain Crunch tastes like,
I wouldn't be able say it
but I know that this
tastes like Captain Crunch.
- I mean this one actually
really tastes like Captain Crunch.
I'm surprised.
- My mind is blown.
- We're setting the bar very high.
- Very high with this one.
- This is dead on.
(upbeat music)
- You're pulling out
all my favorite cereals.
- Yeah, seriously.
- I'm not a Lucky Charms person.
Whatever it is about like the marshmallows
literally gives me goosebumps.
(laughing)
Like I have chills right now.
- When I was a kid, I would
literally take the entire bag
and I would only eat the marshmallows.
- Should we try it?
I'm super-intrigued.
- Yeah I think we just have to try it.
- Just gotta go for it.
The last one blew us away so.
(slurping)
- Ummmmm.
- Uh oh.
- This is very chocolatey.
- Are you sure?
- I don't think this is right.
- Tastes like very Yoohoo
- Uh huh.
- Like chocolate drink,
not quite chocolate milk.
- Definitely chocolate drink.
- It tastes like Yoohoo.
- Yoohoo.
This is not Lucky Charms.
(laughing)
This frappuccino is fake news.
I'm ready for the next one.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Yay!
- Ew child.
- Probably one of the
best cereals of all time.
- That's a hard agree for me.
- It looks really good.
- Let's do it.
- Alright.
(slurping)
- Hmmm.
- 100%.
Spot on.
- I am excited without even trying it.
Come on now.
That is so good.
- Here is my issue.
This has coffee in it.
And it is ruining it for me.
- They just needed to
leave the coffee out of it.
- So everything about
this one hit the mark.
The look, the flavor.
- God, get this out of my face.
(laughing)
You're drinking more.
- I really liked the Captain Crunch one
but the best one was definitely
the Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
- Yeah I think
I think I'm on the same team as that.
Crunch-a-tize me Captain all day.
- The Captain Crunch
was like so surprising.
No way could a drink
taste like Captain Crunch.
- I had no idea that they could do that.
- Some barista in a far
off land probably smoked
eight bowls
(laughing)
and then they were like
I'm going to create a line
of cereal frappuccinos.
- [Woman] It makes sense.